from the police in bristol detective
chief inspector from mainland somerset
police i'd like to give you an update on
the investigation into the missing
person
charlotte bevin and her daughter
yesterday lunchtime a member of the
public was walking along the cliff path
along the cliff face behind me
i noticed those distinctive white
slippers
that's very similar to the ones
charlotte was wearing when she left the
hospital the day before yesterday
and a multi-coloured blanket is quite
distinctive the member of the public saw
those on
the cliff side of a small fence and
thought they were suspicious
but didn't really know why
as a result of the media coverage
yesterday
that person put two and two together
effectively uh rang us at eight o'clock
yesterday evening and we attended the
scene and started with an extensive
search of the cliff face using uh
specialist
search teams and the force helicopter
unfortunately that led us to finding
the body of a woman
who has since been formally identified
as charlotte bevan
the search of the cliff face continued
throughout the night uh we're very keen
to try and locate
zany tiana who is charlotte's
newborn daughter
i regret to inform you that a short time
ago
on the cliff face
close to charlotte
the the body of a small baby girl has
been found
no formal identification has so far
taken place
but we anticipate that is going to be
charlotte's daughter
this is a a dreadful
awful frustrating business
and our thoughts are with the family at
this time
thank you very much